foreign
happy Friday I'm Jack Van Horn from the
University of Virginia and I am very proud
to welcome you to this edition of our 2022-2023
foundations of biomedical data science seminar
Series this lecture series is supported
by uva's integrated translational Health
Institute of Virginia the UVA brain Institute
the College of Arts and Sciences the school
of data science and through a grant from the
National Institutes of General Medical Sciences
since 2016 the foundations of biomedical data
science seminar Series has focused on the use of
data science methodologies artificial intelligence
deep learning and statistical modeling as they
pertain to different themes in the biomedical
and Health Sciences this year's theme is data
science and the public health consequences
of the covid-19 pandemic where each Friday
we enjoy presentations from leading thinkers
about the issues the promise the opportunities
and the hurdles associated with understanding
the secondary health effects of covet 19. these
include delayed Health checkups and treatments
mental health drug abuse increased obesity and
the long lingering health effects associated with
the SARS covid-19 virus participants selected in
our biomedical data science Innovation lab
program will leverage these presentations as
vital material for our culminating in-person Grant
project development Workshop to be held at the
lodge at St Edwards Park in Seattle Washington
in June of 2023. I am delighted to welcome our
speaker today Dr Jason Xu from the Department
of statistical science at Duke University Jason
is an assistant professor in the department of
statistical science with a secondary appointment
by courtesy in biostatistics and bioinformatics
prior to joining The Faculty at Duke Jason worked
at the University of California Los Angeles with
support from the NSF mathematical sciences and
postdoctoral research Fellowship he completed his
PhD in statistics at the University of Washington
in Seattle where his work was funded by and ndseg
fellowship and Dr Xu grew up in Tucson where he
received his BS in mathematics from the University
of Arizona in 2012. in continuing with our 2023
biomedical data science seminar series theme
today's lecture is entitled likelihood based
methods for fitting stochastic epidemic models to
noisy data due to noisy data observational data
or non-linear Dynamics even simple stochastic
epidemic models such as the sir model present
significant challenges for inferences as a result
likelihood-based inference is typically considered
Out Of Reach In The Presence of missing data
and practitioners often resort to simulation
methods or approximations that make bias
conclusions and reduce interpretability
motivated by a number of these challenges Jason is
going to share with us today how a data augmented
approach successfully learns interpretable
epidemic parameters and scales to handle large
realistic data settings efficiently as always we
are streaming this lecture live and for recording
via YouTube If you are watching on YouTube thank
you for joining us also our specially selected
2022-23-23 biomedical data science Innovation
lab participants and alumni are encouraged to
submit any questions they have by the chat feature
in their Zoom sessions I will synthesize these
questions and ask them on your behalf during
the last 10 minutes or so of the lecture and
with that welcome Jason we are so excited to
hear from you thank you so much Jack for the
introduction and thank you all for being here and
for the invitation to speak in this great series
um my talk as you might be able to tell from the
title is going to be biased toward statistical
inference I'm a statistician and um some of
the work is kind of technical in nature it's
methodological but I'm really excited to talk
about it with such a broad audience coming from
all sorts of different backgrounds which as we've
seen is so important to address everything since
this pandemic um and a lot of these challenges
kind of go back of course the long mathematical
tradition for modeling epidemics um a lot of this
work has been around since before the pandemic but
also the sort of realizations we've encountered
with the data that have come up and the sort of
new ways we can study Dynamics as a disease
moves through a population has spurred a lot
of new development for these methods alongside
computational developments in the modern in the
modern world so without further Ado I'll go ahead
and get started on my slides um I do want to say
again it's I try to make some of the technical
stuff there for concreteness but also I try to
make it so that the overall theme will hopefully
come through even without understanding all of
the technical details and I'm always happy to take
questions of course for anything that's not clear
so uh of course this is kind of about epidemic
models and we know that this is related to the
pandemic for this year's theme but I just want to
emphasize that in many disciplines uh Beyond just
sort of the spread of disease uh for instance
computer scientists might need to look at how
ideas or information or memes spread across a
network and of course economists might want to
look at how Behavior spreads among individuals
in some kind of community but in many of these
disciplines we want to understand the
spread of something like disease-like
and uh in in my own view on on these models
because there's such a great literature from
so many different disciplines uh we think that's
at least some of the things we want our models to
reflect is the mechanics of how this disease or
contagion is spreading um I'm a statistician so
I'm biased toward wanting some kind of Randomness
so I'm I'm going to be talking about stochastic
models where not everything is predetermined by
the specifics of the rules you specify and the
parameters but there is some Randomness in how the
process evolves and uh one thing that I'll mention
in this talk is that we'd like to account for some
structure and rates of contacts in the population
and that's something that's not always done in
sort of uh many of these studies today even though
we know that these rates are going to have a big
effect on how the disease spreads and so why don't
people account for all of these pretty simple
things all the time well basically doing sort
of rigorous inference can be a challenging math
problem or even when the math is known it can be
a challenging Computing problem and this is true
even in some of the simplest models that many of
you have heard of so what I'm talking about today
is something called Data augmentation which is not
a new idea it's been around for a long time and
even in the 90s people have studied some of these
simple models under this perspective but there are
a lot of computational limitations to the general
idea that we're hoping to revisit and revive
and in particular are are revisiting of this
approach will hopefully be very complementary to
the dominant ways that people look at stochastic
models of disease which relies on rather intensive
simulation as we'll see so let's talk about these
epidemic models uh first the compartmental
models of infection such as Sir this is what
Jack mentioned in my abstract this is going to
be the focus of the kinds of model we talk about
today and this goes back almost 100 years ago
to the work of sir kermack and mckendrick and
it describes how a disease process moves between
groups in a population where those individuals are
grouped by disease status so in the simplest case
you have susceptible people who are being infected
by some population rate here it looks like beta
times s times I and then those people are gonna
when they become infected they move to the eye
compartment which is the Infectious individuals
and then those individuals will recover or be
removed because of death or something like that
from the population at some other rate which looks
like it's gamma times the Infectious population
so in this very simple model there's just two
parameters beta and gamma and classically in their
work and they've also described General versions
even in that original paper and there are many
variations on such models but these compartmental
models they were typically proposed and still
mostly studied today under uh what we'll call a
deterministic dynamical system okay so when I say
ode I mean that this set of equations is they're
called Ordinary differential equations and that's
how that describes the disease flow but
these equations just tell you basically
curves that are preordained once you give me
beta and S beta and gamma and the populations
so instead what we want to talk about today is
basically the analogous model but it's going to be
a stochastic or random version of those Dynamics
okay and so in this case I'm basically going to
replace that set of differential equations without
going into too much detail yet by uh some random
processes in particular this is going to be
what's called a continuous time markup chain
now in this model when I have a realization of the
curve like this it's actually not smooth which is
what they would look like under that first
model I showed you rather the the population
can go you know there can be little jumps
depending on these random events that are
occurring and I would say that the parameters
under this model can also be more interpretable
in addition to having Randomness that helps us
estimate the uncertainty in our parameters so
for instance a lot of Public Health officials
are very interested in estimating things like
basic reproductive numbers and oftentimes in
words such a quantity is defined as the average
number of secondary infections caused by an
infectious person and so you know that that
can be somewhat vague in a deterministic model
even though there are equations to get at that
it doesn't always align with most Layman's
notion of the word average right which is
often a statistical average like you take a lot
of numbers and you average it so in this case
if I have random variables first of all this
quantity is directly related to the parameters
the interpretable parameters I want to estimate
from the data and for they're more because it's
a stochastic model I really know what this
notion of average means in an intuitive way
one other thing I want to mention is when
we write down these models with equations
such as this it is assuming already under the
hood that there's random mixing going on which
means that all the susceptibles and infectious
people are bumping at each other uniformly and
at a constant rate so there's no structure
in the population it your behavior doesn't
change depending on your disease status
and that might not be very desirable for
uh studying outbreaks especially things like
covet when the behavioral contact patterns
are changing very much throughout the pandemic
with different policies and different behaviors
so this this talk we're not actually going to
talk about covet data per se we're going to be
motivated by a mobile health study that was
collected by a colleague Allison Aiello in a
study called xflute and so in this study there's
a bluetooth app that participants were given
that actually pings when two participants are near
enough and then stops pinging when they're far and
this is happening in real time so over the course
of the study we can actually observe these contact
networks between individuals and as you see just
plotting some of the raw data at some of the weeks
we see that certainly it's not a complete Network
which means not all edges are present so of course
not everybody is bumping into everybody else
at a constant rate in fact it's kind of sparse
in terms of the density and so we would like
to for instance not only enable this rigorous
statistical inference but also make these models
more realistic by incorporating such information
and so naturally one might be interested in
Transmission in such a network right when we talk
about this well-mixed setting where everyone's
bumping into everyone one way to kind of represent
this in some mathematical object is let's say we
had a population of only five people we're going
to represent this by a complete graph which
means everybody has the potential to interact
with everyone else that's what the edges denote
but of course if we observe Network information
or so from for instance mobile data we might know
that person one was only in potential contact with
person two three and four and so therefore the
infection could only have spread that way if a
person one was infectious similarly if you wanted
to do contact tracing or something and person
five later got infected at this time you might
know that it could not have been one that was the
source if you have this kind of data and of course
there's a lot of recent growing interest in this
setting but even before getting to that setting
what I want to claim is when you want to do a lot
of the traditional approaches that are kind of
fully rigorous in statistical inference uh even
that simple model that I plotted on the first few
slides is very difficult to to fit exactly okay
and so I'm going to try to motivate why that is
in a little more technical detail soon but first
let's talk about what people do instead because
I know that there are a lot of papers out there
and all sorts of disciplines that say we have
this sir model this complicated model and then
we learn it from data so when people say this I'd
say most of the time especially if it's a model
with a lot of bells and whistles it's quite common
that they're actually doing the inference or the
simulation or the model fitting under some kind
of approximation to the fully stochastic model
anyway of course you could have a deterministic
model but because those pre-ordained curves will
never match the data exactly they will add some
statistical noise Distribution on top of that so
it's a mixture of something that's deterministic
plus Randomness that's not related to the process
itself and that might be a little bit subtle there
are also other stochastic process approximations
so there are other random processes but you might
need to simplify the Dynamics you might have it
evolve discreetly stepwise through time instead of
naturally in a continuous way or you might have an
opposite thing where instead of keeping track
of exact populations you treat everything as a
continuous number when you have a large population
these are called diffusion approximations there's
all sorts of approximations out there so I think
it's really important to know when you're doing
inference under what model because even though
they're often called the same things like sir or
its variants these little approximations can
make big differences in bias your inference
similarly when you actually want to fit these
stochastic models exactly the model is the sort
of predominant method for doing inference is is
often simulation based so there are things like
sequential Monte Carlo things called particle
filtering and they rely on simulating many
realizations of the data from the model itself
and seeing basically how well they match and
then the ones that match well you upgrade
those parameters this is a very cartoonish
way to describe it but the idea is that these
methods are actually very flexible very powerful
but they're pretty hard to implement and they
kind of can work on a case-by-case basis when
you have a data set where it just happens not
to work well it's something called either poor
mixing it can become degenerate and give you a
solution that's just not interpretable at all
and finally because they're so intensive without
really large scale computational resources it's
hard to do this on on large data sets okay
so what we'll focus on is instead of very
classical thing in statistics where we make use
of the likelihood directly to fit these models
and we want to take into account all these
aspects of these models that I've just reviewed
okay so here's a little bit of technical detail
and I hope I just want to illustrate the high
level Point um but give some concreteness so
I've mentioned that in the stochastic case we
have these models being a class of continuous time
Markov chains and that means that the randomness
comes from the fact that we have rates of things
going on in this case infections and recoveries
or maybe more like contact rates and then we
wait a random variable amount of time until
one of these events happens and then the state
jumps to a new process and in a Markov process
that waiting time is something called exponential
and when we have such a nice distribute this nice
distribution has a lot of properties that makes
things mathematically elegant so the likelihood
of the process which describes how well a given
set of parameters explain the data we observe can
be written down in a reasonably manageable form
okay it has this memorylessness property so I'm
not going to give a full overview of this but for
those of you who understand this I hope this gives
more concreteness so this is such a nice form you
know if you were a statistic student even in early
years of your education you would know that In
classical approaches if this quantity called the
likelihood is telling me how well a given set
of parameters Theta supports my data then to
look for inferring the most likely parameters it
would make sense to try to maximize this quantity
with respect to those parameters so using some
pretty simple calculus I can maximize this and
find things called the maximum likely estimators
or if I want to take a Bayesian approach which
we'll focus on later I can do something called
specifying conjugate priors which means updating
my parameters given the data has a really
nice form that's computationally one line
for a computer okay so we want to maximize this
likelihood and so far the likelihood I wrote down
for any continuous time Markov chain which should
include the processes I'll talk about is actually
really straightforward what we need is we see
that these quantities are functions of the total
number of each type of event and the total time
the process spends in each kind of state it has
so where is the difficulty arising you know why
is this talk not over well again the challenges
that in real life when we study epidemics and
collect observational data from surveillance
studies and things like that we're almost never
going to observe all of these quantities that
inform these two uh terms that we need to compute
these estimators just as an example let's say we
have incidence data which is a focus of this talk
so every week maybe this interval is describing
one week I've observed four new infections well
to compute those quantities for instance I'll
need to know the Infectious population and if
I don't know it if I'm only getting data on
new infections it could have started with two
infectious people and given the same number of
recoveries ended with two infectious people that
week or it could have started with more infectious
people and if there was only one recovery
throughout the week I'd have seven here and
not only do the different numbers of infectious
populations account for the likelihood but even
if I change these times slightly for these four
events that will also change the likelihood and
so you could imagine if I can think about put any
number of possible events and Computing all their
probabilities and changing their time slightly
there's actually an infinite number of such step
function looking objects these continuous paths
that are consistent with my observed data right
I can have infinitely many such shapes not
just these two that are consistent with the
fact that there were four new infections and
so mathematically this becomes a hard problem
as you might imagine you have to integrate over
all of that and account for their probabilities
so our goal is to develop a framework that can do
so precisely okay so we want to do inference based
on that exact likelihood even though we have that
missing data and we would also like to not only
do this for sir but to expand it to relax some of
the assumptions and make it more realistic for the
kind of data we have today okay so I know I spend
a lot of time on the intro but I really think that
a lot of my goal on these kinds of talks is really
to motivate the kinds of challenges that some
people are either not even aware they're lurking
when we fit these models or for those of us who
are in technical Fields might be excited to make
further contributions on in terms of the inference
so here we have a little bit of notation for sure
because the approach to to deal with the missing
data is something called Data augmentation
so I want to describe it at a high level
I've already described that if I work with the
data I observe somehow there's an integral in
the background I need to somehow account for all
the missing data all those possible paths each
have their own probabilities under that likelihood
and the likelihood if I have the whole path is the
thing that I've shown do we have a nice equation
for but the likelihood of my observed data somehow
needs to average over all of those possible paths
weighted by their possible probabilities that can
be a really hard problem but if I don't know how
to compute this red term one thing we can do is
it's sort of technical but statisticians have
a well-used class of approaches called Markov
chain Monte Carlo that makes use of a likelihood
to draw samples from the posterior distribution
and basically flipping this term around via Bayes
Rule now if I have access to this blue term that's
the part that I said even sort of young students
in our department can do calculus and deal with
then we can maybe design a sampler that targets
the distribution of both the unobserved states Z
as well as the parameters we care about so Theta
denotes all the parameters whether it's beta the
transmission rate gamma the recovery rate
additional things having to do with contacts
Etc and if I can draw latent variables to
explore the possible values of Z and learn
about their probabilities by targeting this
Bayesian posterior distribution via something
called mcmc then now I can deal with the marginal
distribution or the distribution I cared about in
the first place which is what is the probability
of those parameters given just the observed data
so this is something I don't have time to explain
in one lecture but this is well known which is if
you have this approach that somehow is generating
samples of jointly your parameters you care about
and the missing data well once you want to
marginalize or get rid of the missing data and
just look at the parameters given that posterior
distribution uh you know you're drawing them in
pairs Theta 1 Z1 Theta 2 Z2 you can just ignore
the Z component so think about putting them in
a table and just covering your eye and looking
at the thetas that is now a valid draw from the
posterior we care about from the distribution the
probabilities of the parameters given are observed
data so now I'll describe one implementation of
the strategy for that Network case in a paper
that's again with my collaborators Alison aiella
who is now at Columbia biostat and Alex wolfoski
who is in my department as well as a phenomenal
graduate student who's since graduated fan
okay so this is going to be an
instance of the strategy I've described
now um the network process is actually going
to be very simple like I said we choose to
we want to remove the assumption that this
contact Network between individuals which
of course will have more than five is not just
the complete graph at all points it's in fact
something that depends on the observed links
from our mobile Health Data and so each time
we'll we'll observe some links which can be
encoded in what's called an adjacency Matrix
which means there's a one every time there's
a link between person I and J so I see a link
between person one and two so there's a one here
there's also a link between person one and three
and one and four but we don't see a link between
person one and five similarly person two is only
attached to person one at this time so they're
just the one in his row and zeros elsewhere
now this network is going to be changing over
time right we're relaxing the assumption that it's
complete and fixed so this itself will also be
some Markov process that's changing between zeros
and ones in its entries but what we'd like is that
well these dynamics of how people interact will
depend on the disease status right you might if
you're a one you're interacting with somebody but
now your friend is sick maybe you're more likely
to become a zero which is to stop interacting with
them than if they were healthy and similarly
if you're sick and you have a moral conscious
you you might uh you might stop interacting
with a higher rate than if you weren't sick
so let's define a similar process where if you are
not linked there's some rate of connecting called
Alpha and the subscripts the note the disease
statuses of these individuals that you'll start
interacting and similarly there's some rate for
instance in an exponential distribution with
Omega you'll wait that long but probabilistically
before you break your link uh we'll denote
Omega the links the link break rates this
will be superimposed on top of the same
disease process that people have studied for
a long time but we see how it generalizes the
network being complete so whenever there
is an edge with rate beta which is that
same beta transmission rate in the classical sir
model you'll have i infecting j right similarly
there's a competing rate maybe gamma like the
the waiting time is is first and then person
I would recover before infecting person J so
now I is recovered and J remains susceptible
maybe they'll have other neighbors that
can infect them or maybe they're safe
so we see if you can imagine that if you had a
complete Network then the total number of eyes
infected people that are in contact with Jays when
all edges in the network are present is actually s
times I If s is the total susceptible population
and I is the total infectious population and
that's where the beta times s times I and the
classical model comes from but we're actually
trying to replace that so we see that at the
individual level you have infections recoveries
and different kinds of Link events on all
potential edges in the network so there's a lot
of links but they share these rates now if we're
assuming that sort of we're just going to decrease
the number of parameters by saying well you know
the probability that two healthy people interact
whether they're already recovered or whether
susceptible doesn't really make a difference
so when we superimpose all of these things
together at the population level we have
infection rates occurring at this is sort of poor
notation but it's beta times s i of T so s i of T
is the number of s i edges which in the complete
graph is s of T times I of T so this is slightly
different from that and this is changing all
the time recovery is occurring at a certain rate
that's identical to the original process because
individuals are independently recovering that's
not really dependent on their social network and
then of course there's all these linked terms
that we need to take a lot of Bookkeeping
on the number of different types of pairs
but overall the Dynamics are very tractable it's
still going to belong in this nice mathematical
class of continuous time markup chains and if
I wrote down the likelihood even though there's
tons of jargon in terms of the notation you can
trust that it's just as nice of a mathematical
form that's manageable basically there are these
there's these kinds of rates under these kinds
of waiting times and all of these things are
computable you can do the nice calculus here
it's the same simple form but with more quantities
and more notation okay so just to validate the
model we ran simulation studies where again like
you you want to be able to recover the parameters
under the model if that generated your data so
in these studies we simulate data from our model
and we let the we let the simulation go as we
have more and more events so we think that with
more and more data the more events we observe the
better our estimates should be and so holding out
the events and and using our estimators the sort
of the forms we've derived um for each of these
rates as the pandemic simulated pandemic goes on
we do see that with more and more data empirically
these estimates are becoming consistent they're
getting around the ground truth that we simulated
them from which is the black lines and so this
is just showing four repeats but of course we
did much more simulations in the tables in the
paper which you can check out if you're curious
and so let's talk really briefly about
the actual application to the xflu data
set right so we've we validated the likelihood
we have a lot more simulation studies to look
at things like frequentis properties are
the confidence intervals correctly doing
the nominal coverage and that's all in the
paper and I'll give you references at the end
but let's now talk about how how can we use this
nice tractable likelihood in the more challenging
setting I've been motivating this whole time
right what I'm saying here is we still have the
nice closed form Solutions at the beginning of the
talk and if I simulate the epidemic I can look at
the event times and the dwell times the things I
need but in more notation here and I can estimate
things correctly so basically this checks that our
formulas are correct but again I need to somehow
apply this to the case where I have missing data
where I get to use this data augmented strategy in
accounting for the missing data by moving around
latent variables for the unobserved quantities
and proposing them efficiently to explore the
space of unobserved quantities effectively
so in our problem setting for instance in the
setting that this exclude study motivates you
might have weekly health status reports so of
course this is not monitored continuously in
time every week we'll have sort of recovery
reports from surveys on when these studied
participants feel better or when they're sick and
we do continuously observe the network which is
really nice right because of those cell phones in
the study that part we don't have missing data on
their in their Link in creations and deletions
but we do have this data split up by weeks and
so we know for instance in the elf week there
are some L new recoveries but we need to know
the times of these events just like that figure I
showed you or else we don't know the likelihoods
um these nice blue quantities that we used
for this simulation study so now we need to
do something augmented we're not only estimating
beta and gamma and Omega and Alphas but we're also
estimating all of these unknown times R which
is a much more High dimensional problem right
you had a couple parameters and a nice model
and now you have a new variable for each person
furthermore the sort of structure of
this latent space is quite constrained
right it needs to obey the Dynamics of the
process but it also needs to obey all the
constraints from that observed Network right
you can't have somebody recover too soon if
later their only link gets infected because
that person needs some explainable infector
so you can imagine it's kind of the structure
of this problem is rather tricky but it's also
a fascinating math problem and so how does data
augmented mcmc look there's really two steps in
terms of describing the algorithm as a high
level so it looks easier than it is the first
is the data augmentation step I mean we have
these observed data but each one has a couple
of missing variables and we need to propose
new configurations you know we don't know when
the recovery times are let's propose different
ones move the potential times around and based
on the likelihoods the probabilities of these
configurations learn things jointly with the data
so we need to be able to propose those recovery
times and compute their probabilities under those
current parameters as well as all the constraints
by our data now given the current setting of
potential recovery times and we can now update the
parameters and this kind of step is going to be
nice this is again the whole idea of having a nice
model with a good well-behaved likelihood function
when all the data are observed is because when I
fixed a potential configuration of the unobserved
data in this completed setting I can then do
a nice parameter update I can learn beta and
gamma and everything else well so we're going to
alternate between proposing things that we don't
have by Computing the missing data in some sense
and then using all that information to have a nice
mathematical object that we can use to learn the
parameters okay and so there's a lot of theory on
why this is actually doing exact inference under
the model I was moving away from these biased
approximations which again are very effective
they're very useful but you could imagine at the
very least that this becomes feasible it actually
serves for the first time as a baseline where you
can you can use a faster you know fancier method
um but if you don't have guarantees on that method
you can compare how well it's doing in a setting
uh with this method and then if it's doing well
you can feel more confident in using it for
settings where this might be difficult okay
so here's the high level idea again there's too
much notation but I hope I've explained the idea
and then the first step like I said is the by far
the harder step you have to propose these things
I've alluded to the fact that they need to respect
all the constraints from the network and so I'm
actually not going to go into this slide what
I want to do is just emphasize the result which
is this really was the work of that phenomenal
graduate student a fan was able to derive a step
that not only moves around those unknown times
in a way that's guaranteed to respect the data
because you could imagine you know you can have
a simple algorithm that says oh well this person
recovered too soon and there's a contradiction
so I now need to add some time to their recovery
when you when you have a clunky algorithm that
you know just moves things around until all the
constraints are satisfied at the end of the day
the probability of all the things you chose to
do in those steps with all these if statements
can be a messy thing to work with instead the
step that we have for step one is going to respect
all the constraints but actually be what's called
a conditional draw off from its distribution so
what we mean is that the way that the algorithm
proposes these missing values is exactly according
to the probabilities they should be distributed
under so that we get to accept every proposal we
don't have to reject some because the probability
was too low so that's something again quite
subtle but if you work on Markov chain Monte
Carlo you'll immediately recognize sort of the
the advantages to having something that's what's
called a Gib step or a conditional draw from a
probability of distribution given everything else
so I hope it won't get any more technical than
that but I hope the high level idea makes sense
for those of you who aren't technical so
what I mean like I said is once you have
the proposed missing data all of the updates for
the parameters are really really nice so in this
case you know the formulas look kind of crazy but
this is one line in a computer an r and when you
have functions like this sampling from a known
distribution like a gamma function it's super
easy super fast and so we're very happy with these
kinds of estimates every time they have a sampler
and so the sampler alternates like
this and tends to perform quite well
so I don't want to talk too much about the real
data because uh what I really really want to
focus on in this talk is just you know giving an
overview of the methodology but we should at least
you know convince you that this was able to work
well on the motivating example so in this case
we have a study on college campus of flu-like
transmissions and uh it's quite complicated
because we have about 600 students over 10
weeks there's a little break in the middle
we have tons of network events observed and we
definitely observe low Network density in the
Raw data which motivates the fact that we need to
relax those well-mixed Assumption of these novels
now just going on to the to the analysis we were
able to run that data augmented mcmc and so for
the first time on this data set we were able
to do rigorous statistical inference on jointly
estimating all the parameters right so we have the
likelihood of this exact model and then we're able
to do not only estimation so here we're reporting
the posterior means of all the parameters
but we also have you know the corresponding
uncertainty quantification so right now I happen
to be reporting the 2.5 to 97.5 uh quantiles
so in this case 95 posterior credible intervals
um and again the numbers might not mean too much
for you this is some study of dynamics of an
outbreak on a college campus but uh you know it's
it's really for the first time the methodology is
saying that here's estimates jointly um and in
a fully stochastic model that incorporates the
Dynamics of the network and not only that but
if you believe that this is your model right
which is a big if this is something that's really
important if you believe that this is your model
then the uncertainty estimation coming out of
it is exact right so this is exactly the way to
quantify how much Faith you should have in your
parameter estimates if you believe in the model
and there's a whole other can of worms there which
the likelihood actually really helps with so if
you don't know whether this is the model because
there's overall likelihood scores of these best
estimates of the parameters you can do all sorts
of things that are rigorous that are steeped
in information theoretic criteria to do model
selection to ask yourself is this model sufficient
to explain the data or for instance on the other
hand is it too rich did I put in too much stuff
in the model and I'm at risk of overfitting so
that my predictions are unstable so all of these
things statisticians are very aware of that
we really like to make you know predictions
to make inferences and to draw conclusions from
the data in a principled manner a lot of these
things revolve around this likelihood function so
the purpose of this is to really motivate that we
can do likelihood-based inference for these models
even though a lot of people have sort of written
that approach off as interactable and just to
actually talk about the estimates a little bit
you know we do have sort of sensical estimates
based on the uh the pilot studies that didn't
have statistics for for all of these parameters
they're not super easy to interpret uh like I
mean they're interpretable but it's not easy to
look at the table because of scaling for instance
this rate looks so high but it's because there
are much more links between healthy people than
others you know most of the people are linked but
healthy but but it does just to sort of interpret
some of these things there's a strong internal
force of infection because we do have an external
infection rate which details are in the paper uh
and there's slow transmission across the campus
with quick recovery and in general the contacts
were very short and the context being short could
have been estimated independently of course from
the data but now we're having the Dynamics of that
affect our estimates of the parameters again if we
did not account for that these parameter estimates
could be very biased which we've seen in the paper
as well and not included in these slides great
so in this first paper you know the one I've
been focusing on for the core of this talk
we've already seen that we can design these
generative models in the tradition of these
compartmental models but also relax some of
these maybe stringent assumptions such as
well mixing and in this case it describes the
interplay between the disease process and the
contact process right not only are we seeing how
the disease progresses conditional on a network
but also how does the Network's rates change
conditional on the current disease status of
those people so it's really interweaving and
um of course statistically the whole idea is to
enable exact inference so that if you believe
in a certain model you can you can know that
your estimates are are correct and the uncertainty
more importantly is correct but furthermore if you
don't know which model to choose you can have this
criteria to uh to select models within a class
now I would say there's still a lot of limitations
so this is one thing I want to talk about for the
remainder of this talk of course you know we have
certain mathematical assumptions right now we
were talking about Markov models where there's an
exponential recovery time and exponential time for
infectiousness and many people have observed that
this is not true for many diseases it's not a good
fit right so right now we're trying to see well
given that we've Revisited this augmented approach
for posterior inference for Bayesian inference
how can we build upon this Foundation to expand
the class of model complexity model realism so
that not only is the inference correct under the
model but we can do this for more and more models
that people want to investigate so just a couple
previews here we have some new work that not
only is going to deal with the stuff in missing
recovery times but also looks at when you don't
even have any information on the infection times
of individuals and that actually makes the problem
much harder because these things are not only very
high dimensional but quite correlated with one
another in this same line of work we're going to
be able to accommodate the semi-markov case where
these times are not necessarily exponentially
distributed so for those of us who do mathematics
you might be aware that this is this is a big
Leap Forward because it really changes the whole
structure of these likelihoods and everything else
um and again this stuff has been investigated
in the past but has really been limited to small
outbreaks and requires a lot of compute time
whereas our current uh directions using this
data augmented approach and these really nice
proposal densities that we've engineered uh
is able to do this inference on a single laptop
like a you know regular MacBook for really large
outbreaks in just minutes and so this is a hugely
compared to a lot of the existing methodologies in
terms of computational time and of course some of
the existing methodologies the dominant approaches
for stochastic models are much more flexible
than what we have for now but like I said we're
building upon this Foundation very excited for
these future directions I'll probably skip this
slide but it's trying to tell you that to design
these nice effective proposals we really need to
just come up with similar stochastic processes
with slightly simpler dynamics that are more
mathematically trackable and you know unlike these
other approximation approaches which then does
inference under that simpler process we can use
these processes to explore the latent variables
doing step one in the data augmented approach but
then correct their likelihoods so that at the end
of the day we're actually doing inference under
the exact process the original one that we posited
when we have such proposals the uh the step
one the kind of latent variable update can be
really really nice you can look at that pseudo
code here you can generate the entire epidemic
in terms of the infection times and removal
times and basically two joint lines of code
so you don't need to do things sequentially for
those of you who simulate epidemics and know how
intensive that can be you can really place them
down because of the sort of decoupled dynamics of
these similar processes so again this is just
a preview I don't expect to cover two things
in technical detail on talk um but is the the
directions we're building upon uh from from that
these approximations even when you only have
let me see on the caption you only have five
observation times throughout a whole epidemic that
dies out and we see that the approximations are
quite far from the original process in Gray but
as you increase the number of observations to even
just 10 you see that it's much more faithful it's
almost looking like the exact original process and
when you have more and more observations which of
course is more and more possible these days and
the data we collect it's basically uh identical
Dynamics as the target process so it's really
really promising and I'm really excited to share
that work uh soon as it keeps coming out we've
also applied that kind of work to real data and
so many of you who study disease are familiar with
this uh this Ebola pandemic in Western Africa some
years ago and many of the studies for instance the
World Health Organization based a lot of their
estimates on these deterministic models and even
there they had to do a couple rather heuristic
parametrizations of the transmission rates and
things like that whereas we can finally apply this
completely stochastic approach to analyze data
of this scale in just a couple of minutes on one
laptop again so this is this is a big breakthrough
in terms of computation and of course we really
are just Reviving classical ideas that do exact
inference that have been around for a while but
with a new modern lens for the kind of data and
Computing resources we have today and the sort of
new advances in Bayesian statistical methodology
so sort of a lot of exciting things and analyzing
all sorts of partially observed epidemic data
okay so I'll wrap up pretty soon here I just
want to close by saying that a fully stochastic
modeling has a lot of advantages right I kind of
delved right into this but why do we care about
the stochastic model approach I would say that
they're a little more interpretable than these
deterministic models right when you have things
like the probability of an outbreak that that has
meaning under the parameters in a stochastic model
where in a deterministic model you you just have
curves dictating its size but it's it's already
going to have an outbreak which is a strange
thing to have when you're doing inference and
predictions the uncertainty quantification is more
interpretable and also you know coincides with the
estimation when we have likelihood-based inference
and eventually when we build out this framework
to have richer models that are more more realistic
to describe all the data we have this will lead
to very reliable forecasting and decision making
right we can quantify whether we're overfitting we
can quantify how well we're capturing the data and
the uncertainty quantification the confidence or
credible intervals coming out of the inference are
trustworthy Again The Continuous time Markov chain
framework we focused on here is is very classical
for mathematicians and the long line of modeling
alongside epidemiologists but it's extensible in
many open directions we've already been relaxing
some of these distributional assumptions to make
this super flexible and in one example here we've
relaxed the while mixing assumption to incorporate
networks but we're also working to incorporate
spatial data all sorts of different sources from
phylogenetic information and again like from a
likelihood based approach there are ways to to
integrate these things naturally there's
still a lot of open directions and things
we're working toward as well as things that we'd
like other people to work towards so right now
we haven't really dealt with the case which is
very natural from a data perspective they have
multiple strains uh multiple compartments like
not just in terms of disease status but in strata
of the population we have been working already on
different individual level covariates to add more
heterogeneity to the Dynamics and things like
missing data under unreliable reporting rates
uh my colleague Alexander wolfowski is already
working on the network missing this problem and
I've been thinking a lot on more realistic random
graph models for these Network Dynamics uh we've
been working on some things for change Point
detection when the force of infection beta is
also changing through time again you don't want
it to be too flexible or else your model can fit
anything but so you want it to be flexible
enough but also parsimonious enough so that
you don't have volatile predictions and all sorts
of things in particular would want to really have
hybrids right we've I've overviewed all this kind
of work that I said this is complementary to and
I don't take issue with that kind of work I just
think that this this line of work was somewhat
abandoned for because it was a hard math problem
and it was computationally intractable and I'm
saying that it's not necessarily intractable if
we're willing to think hard about this but we can
probably take it even further by uh looking
for these connections explicitly with the
other things that people are doing in this field
many of which is also very exciting methodology
so with that I'll wrap up I wanted to thank
especially the student collaborators here
I've mentioned fanbu who was the lead author on
this uh Network paper and she's going to start
a faculty position at Michigan's biostats
Department we're very proud of her Raphael
is currently a PhD student advised by me at
Duke and is doing a lot of the really exciting
stuff on computation for these fully missing
data settings and the semi-markovian settings
and Jenny Huang is an outstanding undergraduate
actually who is unfortunately already committed
to a PhD program for those of you who might be
in the market to recruit Talent she's joining
mit's eecs program and she's been working on
a lot of the dynamic change Point detection
stuff for time varying transmission rates under
these models so I'll just leave you with this
slide on some of the references a partial
list of references these papers are under
various pre-print statuses submission statuses
and publication statuses and include my other
collaborators who are really wonderful to work
with throughout this whole process so with that
thank you very much for uh for your time and
for listening Jason thank you you so much wow
what an interesting uh line of kind of attack on
this interesting challenging problem um and I'm
sure lots of people have questions for you and I
hope they can ask them in the chat or maybe reach
out to you directly via email um you mentioned
um exploring other multi-compartmental kind of
approaches can you describe a few of what those
might be and also what does that do to some of
the computations some of the math and computation
times that might be involved yeah that's a great
question and so there there's a couple different
directions and I'm going to mention two of them so
we talked about sort of uh I guess it's on this
last slide for things like multiple strains and
compartments so one very natural thing I focused
on Sir here but there's of course ones with more
stages there's s-e-i-r where the latent stage
is is even harder to observe so for these kinds
of models where there are more sequential stages
it's basically the challenge is to design these
proposals in a way that is still identifiable so
you can actually explore the latent compartments
in a way that you can learn from the data because
you can't observe there's more that you can't
observe and so the mathematics needs to change
on the other hand when it's simply sort of more
levels like maybe I have this identical model
but I have adults and children right and this
is this is a big thing right epidemiologists care
about how the Dynamics with young people might be
different from different strata what I would call
strata in the age structure other structure in
the population and so in those cases I would say
a lot of the mathematics goes through but then
computation is what's increasing in complexity
right you could imagine it's not necessarily
just double the computation when you have double
the strata but because of the connections between
things and how you closet the relationships it
can grow even faster than that in complexity so
um there's all sorts of these uh sort of
trade-offs to balance but I think it's absolutely
something that's worth investigating right so this
kind of heterogeneity you can have for instance
household structure as well right you would have
two levels in a hierarchy where you have this
kind of network thing between people then you
also have household units and their Dynamics so
um there's kind of going this way and going this
way in terms of expanding the compartments and
there's different challenges that arise one of
the characteristics of exponential distributions
and sort of embedded in Markov chain modeling is
the notion of memorylessness and some people may
not be familiar with that on what that concept
May mean mathematically and what it means in the
context of these models would you mind doing as a
solid and explaining what that means absolutely I
barely mentioned that at all and I think you know
I'm trying to tiptoe between too much technical
difficulty but like also I want to this is
actually a really important point right so
like I said these random models they're they're
processes so the time between events has to follow
some random variable and the reason that people
like to choose exponentials is because they're
really mathematically convenient they have this
memorylessness which is to say that let's say
you know I person one is uh sick in week one week
two they're still sick right the memorylessness is
saying that well when I look at the mathematical
properties like the probability they recover at a
certain time I actually don't even need to think
about the fact that they were already sick for
a whole week okay and that that of course
makes the math easier because otherwise I
incur this mathematical debt of having to remember
exactly when everybody got sick and changing the
probabilities based on how long they've already
been sick now on the other hand now that I've
revealed that you could absolutely imagine why an
epidemiologist would say hey that's not a really
realistic assumption because the expert Financial
distribution mathematically also has what's
called fat tails which means that there's a lot of
probability for the extreme events as well so you
could imagine well if every time I'm like giving
a fresh new coin flip on whether this person is
going to recover if a particular person happens to
have you know uh survived for three weeks in a row
and the recovery period tends to be much shorter
than that this is a really unlikely event so the
model is kind of giving Mass probability Mass to
something that's unrealistic biologically so many
people want to have distributions that are more
realistic that have a memory property that says
well this person hasn't recovered yet but already
been sick for two weeks so they're probably they
recover is soon is very high the exponential one
that probability doesn't change over time which
helps us mathematically but is not that realistic
like I said we have new work that actually
addresses this very flexibly but is not focused
on here today that's a great question thank you
you mentioned uh also that um some of the
Assumption about that exponentiality is
may not be always true um are there any other
shapes of distributions um you know shape I guess
a kind of morphometry of other distributions
which might be suitable for the modeling may
have memoryless processes um or maybe just you
know also convenience for a variety of reasons
yeah that's also a great question so I mean in
particular like I said we've been developing
methods for all sorts of General processes with
different what's called renewal distributions but
just two that I'll mention you know something
that people have looked at in the past is
gamma distributions and the reason is because
statistically some Gammas have multiple parameters
but some members of that family of distribution
are actually the the sum of exponentials so it's
it's kind of a very natural extension well
you could imagine that this is a larger class
um and another thing that we've been working with
is the class of viable distributions and that has
some uh some nice ramifications from extreme
value Theory which makes things more robust um
so there's all sorts of different choices here and
we've we've only investigated a couple so far but
the methodologies in general and I think there's
a lot of uh you know there's a lot of nice again
it's it's an interesting Balancing Act between
finding things that are nice enough mathematically
but also Rich enough to describe what's going on
in a way that's satisfying to people who actually
deal with the data right so mathematically we
would exponentials are on one end of that spectrum
because they're the nicest one but they're just
simply not appropriate for many uh for instance
infectiousness distributions so I would say a
good starting point and something that's been
looked at in the literature in different contexts
are both the gamma family and the Bible family
have you ever put any of these uh simulations
like in motion to try to so I guess to say uh
in silico create a little community that have
its yeah have it you know a monkey with the
assumptions of mixing rates and that sort of thing
and then uh kind of watch these probabilities
um play out sort of again in a little in silico
Petri dish does that make sense absolutely it
makes sense and we this is something that we
absolutely have done I I didn't really go into
it in this talk uh it's in the paper I did mention
though that there was a simulation study where we
validate the equations but basically the way
that works is that we specify the Dynamics the
probability laws of the model and we do simulate a
little outbreak according to those rules and then
let's say we would hold out we would pretend that
we didn't simulate it and know everything so we
would now say oh I'm only gonna I'm gonna throw
away all the data that I get to see except for
the same sort of quantities I would see in an
observational study and that's super important
to you know then employ the a methodology
we developed on that setting where we're
artificially only giving ourselves access to some
data but we're seeing how well we can learn the
rest right so so we've done all sorts of studies
like that in the paper but to another part of the
question the interesting thing is like I said you
can you can you can validate whether the inference
is correct under the model you specify but a
sort of related challenge is well how can you
simulate things well for unobserved quantities
so I guess what I'm thinking of is you know in
our case we fully observe the mobile contact
Network and so we can we can learn the rates
and look at how that affects the Transmissions
but now let's say this is something I again
didn't go into but at the end I said what if
we could look at more realistic random graph
models and what I mean by that is you know if you
now have a setting where you want some Network to
describe Behavior but you're in a setting where
you don't have for instance a cell phone study
so you don't observe the network and now you want
to simulate that Network like you're suggesting
um in a way that's plausible that might explain
the way people are are moving even though you
don't observe it right so right in in our in our
methodology we have motivated how we don't observe
the recovery times but we're able to infer them
this is sort of an even harder problem where you
don't observe the networks but you like to posit a
model that you can simulate potential networks and
so that can be hard because a lot of times the the
nice map again the nice mathematical models many
of them might not reflect some things you tend to
observe in real life so you might have a certain
class of models You observe and find there's like
edges that are added and removed but then many of
the observed networks don't have as many triangles
as you would see because in real life my friend of
a friend is more likely to be a friend here and
then if you tweak it by adding you know closing
triangles when you have two friends but then their
friends of friends aren't friends yet that could
introduce new triangles so there's all sorts
of things that have been you know persistent
problems in the literature that are interesting
fastest to think about when you do simulation
yeah um um so some of your equations have
probably struck fear Into the Heart of
several of the biologists who are watching today
um what sort of comment would you have for them
about wanting to participate in activities that
are like like this right what what would they get
out of doing something like this as somebody who
is a you know card carrying biologist for example
yeah that's a great question too I think
it's um part of it the the difference in
things like interpretability and what I keep
saying the uncertainty quantification I think
that difference is a little bit subtle but it's
it's it's something that I think biologists would
absolutely care about which is for instance if
I have a deterministic model where the curve is
governed by the parameters like I said when you
observe counts it's never going to pass perfectly
through that deterministic curve so what a lot
of approaches do that fit the model to data is
they have that curve plus just some probability
distribution like uh I have that mean that curve
describes the mean number of infections but then
I have either gaussian or binomial measurements
from that curve and that amount of noise from
those distributions allows me to have at least
a likelihood of my data that's not zero right
it can be explained it's like oh it didn't match
this curve but because I've only observed a
noisy version so now if I'm a biologist and
I'm you know plugging this into maybe statistical
software where I don't have to look at these scary
equations confidence intervals out of it well
what does the confidence interval mean the only
probability in that model I just described is
coming from the measurement error because I had
a completely deterministic process for the disease
and then the probabilities are on the measurements
of how I observe that fixed curve so you have to
kind of think it's a little bit subtle but it's
like all the uncertainty can be interpreted as my
measurement uncertainty of a process that's fixed
okay so then when you observe when you estimate
beta and then you have a confidence interval
it's just measurement error on beta that's you
know it's not saying that if I have a quantity
like I said in these models if R naught is beta
over gamma basically normalized by the population
I I can't think of this as a statistical average
if beta and gamma are things corresponding to a
fixed curve and I have to think about it as some
other thing that now has uncertainty around how
it was measured whereas in these stochastic
models which you do run into these equations
this is a much more natural quantity because it's
describing the uncertainty in the random process
right because I'm now envisioning the disease
spread itself as a random process I think that's
extremely important and I don't think that it's
always a bad idea to use deterministic models but
I do think it's important to know how to interpret
the uncertainty coming out of your inference
and so my my the really the only way to tell
people to please look at these equations is
to say well look how important it is in sort of
the repercussions of of knowing what model you're
working with right and then if I had to just ease
the notation I would ease the equations themselves
I would just say that you got to trust that even
though there's a lot of notation these things are
nice like if I give notation condensed things
these equations can be derived pen and paper in
a couple minutes and furthermore the whole idea
is that there's a lot of bookkeeping when I write
that exact same equation in a specific instance
for instance in our model but even though these
equations do look daunting like they really
are things where if I have the bookkeeping
to like look at these quantities from the data
I could I could write down these commands in r
in a couple of minutes right I could just put
them in and we did the math so that you can
put in the equations and furthermore we'd hope to
make this even more General we have user-friendly
software as long as it's the high level like PD is
clear which is that there's a stochastic process
model and the inference for the probabilistic
quantification corresponds to the uncertainty in
the process itself I hope that is a little bit
long-winded but I hope it makes sense it does
thank you Jason Jason this was really wonderful
thank you for sharing this uh amazing amount of
work with us uh it looks very exciting and
uh it's very mathematically sophisticated
um and I'm sure that uh with a little bit
of of uh practice and some tutelage even
our biologists will be able to kind
of come to grips with it uh it's it's
really wonderful stuff and thank you
for sharing these references as well
um and kudos to you and to your colleagues for
uh putting this together so um with that Jason
thank you once again thank you everybody who
joined us and everyone have a wonderful weekend
and uh we'll talk to you next week thank you so
much thanks for having me again thank you Jason